hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
with Rachel Cushing who you might have
seen on the Schmo down I brought her
here today she is the first brand new
guest never been on the real rejects
before starting off the new year right
how do you feel to be here Rachel I'm
excited to be here thank you for the
invite are you nervous are you tense in
the shoulders no I feel like I'm feeling
relaxed really I prefer the guest to be
as uncomfortable as I prefer if your
stress and you blank out when you're
talking now if anyone has seen the Schmo
Don everyone knows that I always do way
better than rachel has ever done throw
down it's kind of embarrassing for her
to be sitting next to me because I
always know way more than her now rachel
is known to be one of the smartest
people in the Schmo down so I'm so happy
to have you here we're gonna shoot an
Oscar movie list a little bit later
prediction list but in the meantime
let's check out some trailers right
that's what we do here have you heard of
the movie Tully
I have not me neither that's why these
are called reactions yeah all right
ready
[Music]
I had this my he must've directed this
totally feels like him
[Music]
[Music]
very judgy there Ron Livingston Melly
I'm here here are you I can't tell them
to be honest okay I'm here to take care
of you what kind of town are we going I
mean this this seemed very jason reitman
like the whole like exploring the life
the drama comedy mixed in Tony's really
good at striking that tone in that
everyday feel too well yeah clearly what
this was going for the the non glamorous
side of being a mother yeah like it's
still kind of quirky but it's also very
life II at the same time you know and
also I really like when Charlize Theron
does roles like this now she can do her
furious aids whatever she's sexy she is
a very beautiful woman but she is a very
very talented actress and I feel like
it's when these films come out like
young adult or monster or this one where
you're reminded yes she's actually
really great actress she was really good
at young at all I don't like that movie
I I would say liked didn't love but that
is not default her acting exactly
exactly yeah
she's that thing where you reader rod
tomatoes score and your life despite in
being okay film Charlize Theron it's
great yeah I feel like we could possibly
land in another situation like this
normally I don't do this but I have to
read the IMDB description right here
okay this film is about Mario her name
is Mario a mother of three including a
newborn who's gifted a night nanny by
her brother wrong living since her
brother has a sense of sheriffs at first
Mario comes to form a unique bond with
the thoughtful surprising sometimes
child young nanny named Polly who was
that was Elizabeth de vikke right Wow
you should compete on the Schmo knows we
can do Davis are you kidding no I'm not
kidding
whatever you well that's why you're here
tell me honestly yeah sure what's cool
about this is they've all worked
together already yeah cuz they all work
together a new adult they're coming back
for this collaboration right here and I
thought this was a really interesting
trailer and the way that are advertising
it because it's called Tully so I
thought I just assumed
Charlize Theron's was Tully the whole
time it's a decent assumption and then
you get to the end of the trailer hi I'm
totally as if it's like a MC you can't
know this totally person is or what this
exactly means but it sounds interesting
I feel like this is really gonna hinge
on knowing who the filmmakers are in the
star of it - yeah absolutely it's and it
was like a more of a teaser feel than a
trailer we know very little it was like
barely any dialogue until the end and I
like those because that's it's about
tone I was unsure about it but it looked
like like you said has a really good
balance between drama comedy I sort of
got like maybe a slightly ominous feel
but maybe deadly right right right this
gonna be like an Oscar Beatty type thing
because I mean the trailers coming out
now and so I imagine the movie would
come out just a few months from now it's
always hard for me to tell with this
kind of stuff a movie dates move all the
time maybe it's a festival thing or
early in the year little drama that
could possibly hopefully it's good and
Charlize Theron is as a talented actress
so I'm gonna implement a rating system
right now I've never had a rating system
okay are you gonna go see it not see it
wait for it on DVD rent it off of a
friend's netflix account wait for a
screener which one welcome to the new
rating system that I'll forget about the
next video issue I will jump cut the
[ __ ] out of this Rachael as an editor
and I'm gonna impress her with my
awesome jump cut skills there's so much
more talented than me in so many other
areas I'm just nervous about you being
why am i the girl why am I the girl this
way you're coming to my home
oh god I gotta do good for her you can
subscribe you can click that
notification really get notified every
time one of our videos is up Rachel
Cushing kindly asks that you follow her
at Twitter
Rachel J Cushing I follow her she tweets
way more than I do and I read every one
of her tweets so make sure to follow her
on Twitter today and become a patron
today today it's like a second youtube
channel go check it out